[Music]
on this Tuesday night marches across
America protests throughout a nation in
pain and the chorus of criticism of the
US presidents tactics the Bible that you
country is crying out for leadership as
Canada's Prime Minister chooses his
words carefully
when asked about Trump black out Tuesday
the new social media movement standing
for racial justice and stumbling blocks
to a solution by fixing Canada's long
term care homes is no easy feat
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
the United States is a country in crisis
tonight for an eighth straight day
Americans took to the streets from New
York City to st. Paul Minnesota to
Houston Texas in Los Angeles California
for the most part they appeared peaceful
killing people not willing to remain
silent
and risk being complicit with nighttime
curfews approaching though in many
cities the threat of more violence looms
after President Donald Trump threatened
to deploy the military of cities and
states failed to stop the protests good
evening and thanks for joining us the
United States of America appears deeply
divided tonight fed up with police
brutality and systemic racial inequality
protesters are demanding accountability
a commitment to change and leadership
that will deliver it President Trump
isn't reaching out to try to bridge that
divide he is deepening it today his
rival Joe Biden in his first public
address since the pandemic put his
campaign on pause warned Americans not
to let rage consume them Donald Trump
has turned this country into a
battlefield riven by old resentments and
fresh fears he thinks division helps him
ask every American look at where we are
now and think anew is this who we are is
this what we want to be is this if we
want to pass on to our children and our
grandchildren fear anger finger-pointing
the country is crying out for leadership
leadership that can recognize pain and
deep grief of communities that have had
a knee on their neck for a long time
there have been calls for president
Trump to address the nation and appeal
for calm he hasn't done that he has said
the biggest victims of the rioting are
peace-loving citizens in the poorest
communities and he will fight to keep
them safe he's threatened to deploy
federal troops to do it
Global's Jackson prosecco is near the
White House tonight Jackson what's the
situation like there now Donna there are
thousands of peaceful protesters in the
street outside the White House but for
the first time tonight they are
separated from police by a three meter
high fence which was installed after
yesterday's chaos here and at locations
across Washington people have taken to
the streets in defiance of a local
curfew and despite the fact that the
military is now patrolling the streets
in a preview of what might come to the
rest of America the US military is now
patrolling the streets of Washington on
orders of the president army helicopters
fly low a tactic to scare away
protesters I don't think that our the
military should be used on the streets
of American cities against Americans and
I definitely don't think it should be
done for a show the militarization of
the US Capitol comes as Donald Trump
draws a line in the sand opting for
strongman tactics in a nation consumed
by protests if a city or state refuses
to take the actions that are necessary
to defend the life and property of their
residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for them the abrupt escalation came
after federal officials moved in with
force to disperse peaceful crowds
outside the White House Monday
moments later the president walked
through the freshly cleared streets to
stage a photo-op at the so-called Church
of the presidents in a move meant to
portray strength church leaders who were
not told of the visit voiced objections
and held up a Bible as if it were a prop
or an extension of his military and
authoritarian position and stood in
front of our building as if it were a
backdrop
for his agenda the White House has not
shown any interest in hearing from
protesters or dealing with concerns
about systemic racism in America with
protests underway in more than 100
American cities mayors and governors are
now left to wonder how much longer
they'll be able to balance the right to
protest against the need to stop the
looting and violence there is some
welcome news from Minnesota tonight that
state has launched investigation into
the Minneapolis police force a civil
rights investigation looking at
practices dating back more than a decade
and tonight a lawyer for George Floyd's
family says they expect that charges
against the additional three officers
involved in the case could be late
within a week Donna Jackson Carrasco
near the White House tonight thanks
Jackson
George Floyd that left behind a
six-year-old daughter and today her
mother Roxy Washington made her first
public comments since Floyd died there's
a little bit of what she said he would
never graduate he will never walk down
justice for him I want justice because
he was good sometimes you only see a
turning point in hindsight but there's a
feeling America might be in one right
now the seedings anger about police
brutality and long-standing racial
inequality goes far beyond an unarmed
black man dying under the knee of a
white police officer in Minneapolis and
it's testing police and political
leaders on Monday after vowing to
dominate the streets president Trump
used a church and a Bible as props for a
photo-op the Episcopal Church got no
advance warning and the presiding bishop
Michael Curry is outraged accusing Trump
of using a church building and the Holy
Bible for partisan political purposes
faith leaders gathered in front of the
church today with a message
for the president other people of faith
asked has the Bible ever been used in a
more disingenuous and exploitative way
those on the religious right though
loved it like the president of the
Congress of Christian leaders who
tweeted I will never forget seeing
president Trump slowly and in total
command walk from the White House
defying those who aim to derail our
national healing by spreading fear hate
and anarchy
today the president went to a shrine to
Pope John Paul a second a visit
condemned by the Archbishop of
Washington
Wilton Gregory he said Pope John Paul
certainly would not condone the use of
tear gas and other deterrence to silence
scatter or intimidate them for a photo
opportunity in order for Trump to walk
to the church Monday federal officers
used force and teargas to clear away
peaceful protesters put outside the
White House this Australian cameraman
and reporter were shoved and hit while
live on air one of numerous examples of
reporters being targeted and attacked by
authorities while trying to document
what's happening freedom of the press is
protected in the First Amendment of the
US Constitution
so is freedom of peaceful assembly it's
hard to know what the president's plan
really is but it feels increasingly
authoritarian President Trump has told
governor's to act or he will mobilize
federal troops and he has the authority
to do so under the insurrection act
Erick Sorenson explains what that is and
how likely Trump is to use it when
federal troops backed up police who
cleared a path for the u.s. president it
was a signal from Donald Trump that he's
willing to smash protests anywhere in
the country that is why I am taking an
immediate presidential action to stop
the violence and restore security and
safety in America it would be
unprecedented on such a scale but not
unheard of the insurrection act in part
empowers
the President to call armed forces and
the National Guard to protect
constitutionally secured rights
typically at a request from a state
governor the act was last used during
the Los Angeles Riots in 1992 under
President George HW Bush and before that
during the presidency of Lyndon Johnson
to quell riots including Detroit in 1967
in both cases the president was asked
for help to initiate the movement of the
troops which the governor had requested
President Dwight Eisenhower once called
in federal troops without a request to
ensure black children could attend the
formerly white school in Little Rock
Arkansas the cornerstone of our Liberty
I don't think it should ever be used to
enforce domestic law unilaterally
against the will of a governor
particularly to move on peaceful
protests that is an entirely
inappropriate use of Department of
Defense resources the president was to
talk about just looting one state
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York has
said no thanks to federal troops other
Democrats say the president's actions
are unconstitutional I fear for the
future of our country that in this time
of immense difficulty our president is
only capable of contributing or division
more fear more chaos to stop the
protests Trump may be prepared to take
on a constitutional challenge he sees it
as a kind of political threat to his
presidency
I think he's demonstrated that he's
willing to test constitutional
boundaries and see where the chips fall
preparing to call in the military has
achieved one thing for president Trump
it has overshadowed news about the novel
coronavirus on his watch Eric Sorenson
global news among the many images that
capture the mood of what's happening
right now
our editorial cartoons Canadian
cartoonist Michael de adder uses an
iceberg to depict how what is captured
on cell phone video is just the tip of
the iceberg that most small daily acts
of racism happen off camera and go
unseen the anger felt in America isn't
confined to its borders nor are acts of
racism any can
especially black Canadians are looking
to Canadian political leaders to respond
and deliver meaningful change here and
when asked about president Trump's
approach Canada's Prime Minister chose
his words carefully abigail Beeman
reports this hell is hell on earth God
love ngah fousey says he deals with
racism in Canada every day harassed by
neighbors stopped by police
now George Floyd's death adds to his
pain flurry of events going through my
mind non-stop 24 hours a day basically
it's just a confirmation of what we knew
is like the the coming the coming race
what we knew was gonna happen Tuesday
the prime minister said he's listening
black Canadians and racialized Canadians
face discrimination as a lived reality
every single day there is systemic
discrimination in Canada but when asked
what he thought of US President Donald
Trump's actions using tear gas to move
protesters for a photo-op
and threatening to call in the military
Trudeau was silent for a very long time
and if you don't want to comment what
message do you think you're sending
we all watch in horror and consternation
what's going on in the United States
judo usually answers in one second that
was 21 and in the end no mention of
Trump's name I think it's important to
condemn what Trump is going to do if
there is calling in of the military and
many people are saying this would be a
violation of constitutional norms in the
United States if there's a massive state
repression that Isaac Saini is a Black
Studies specialist at Dalhousie
University and he's experienced racism
himself in Halifax going public after
one nasty verbal attack against him and
his young daughter on a bus he says
what's going on south of the border is
deeply painful but he also has hope the
multiracial multi-ethnic crowds rallies
and demonstrations demonstrate that this
is not just simply a black protest it's
a black LED protest but they have allies
allies calling for action and change
over rhetoric abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa coming up another controversial
police arrest caught on video this one
happened in Canada
you
an RCMP officer in Nunavut has been
moved to administrative duties after a
troubling video was posted on Facebook
Mercedes Stevenson joins me now from
Ottawa Mercedes what is the video show
what are the RCMP saying about it Donna
it's a pretty shocking video let's watch
it together so you can see exactly what
happens here it starts out where we see
a man he's up in Nunavut and he is lying
in the street at first then he is having
trouble standing he begins to stumble
through the slushy Street and that's
when an RCMP truck sweeps in from the
right side of the video the officer
opens his door and he strikes the man
with it knocking him off his feet that
is certainly not standard police
procedure for arresting somebody the
RCMP say that this all happened last
night at 11:30 p.m. they say they were
called to a call about an intoxicated
man who they say was reportedly fighting
with other people the commanding officer
up there who is Chief Superintendent
Amanda Jones says that she found out
about this video on social media saw it
as soon as she did she immediately
ordered two investigations both an
independent external statutory
investigation and an internal
investigation they're also looking at
whether or not this officer will face
criminal charges in the meantime he has
been removed from the community and he's
been placed on administrative duties but
you can certainly see Donna when you are
looking at this video very very shocking
they're trying to find out what exactly
happened here but this is spreading like
wildfire on social media especially amid
the current political climate Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson thank you
still ahead the challenge of solving
Canada's care home crisis
Kovach 19 has taken a devastating toll
on residents in Canada's long-term care
homes they're among the most vulnerable
to the novel coronavirus in Canada eight
out of ten Kovach 19 related deaths have
happened in long-term care homes many of
the facilities are chronically
underfunded and short-staffed in Ontario
and Quebec the military was called in to
help and the condition soldiers reported
in some of the homes were deplorable at
heartbreaking this week Global News is
taking a deeper look into long-term care
and the challenge of fixing what's
broken here's Ross Lord retired health
and safety inspector Jim chan has this
advice for governments on fixing
long-term care in Canada don't wait to a
crisis situation befall you react and
try to fix the problem in 36 years on
the job Chan noticed public and
nonprofit homes were generally quicker
to fix problems than their private
counterparts some of the the issue can
cost quite a bit of money and so from a
profit point of view some you know
privately owned facility may think that
wow you're gonna cost more money or lots
of money we're gonna challenge your
order there's a growing call for private
operators to be pushed out of long-term
care I think it's a huge problem there
is absolutely no room for private
profiteering off the backs of seniors
who can't get the care that they need
some private companies have managed the
pandemic without any outbreaks others
have had serious challenges but the same
can be said for the public side the
Canadian Institute for health
information or Chi high estimates there
are 2,100 long term care homes in Canada
housing 190,000 people twice as many
women as men guys most recent breakdown
of how they're managed is several years
old the 2014 report shows 44% had
private for-profit operators 29% were
non profit 27% were publicly operated
seeing the complete picture of long-term
care is it easy chi high whose findings
are meant to be used by policymakers
across Canada says only eight of 13
provinces and territories participate
fully in its reporting system and
information vacuum is frustrating some
researchers we have a lot of provinces
who frankly have been increasingly
hiding the data and hiding the
information as the situation's got worse
when you should absolutely be doing the
absolute opposite dr. Samir Sinha at the
National Institute on Aging suggests
there's no room for gaps in information
that could lead to poor decisions
considering 8 in 10 covered 19 deaths
have happened to people in long-term
care the system that cost Canadians 22
billion dollars a year
Ross Laura Global News Halifax in part
to Ross explores what the future of
long-term care might look like including
legislated standards and the possibility
of a greater role for the federal
government that's tomorrow on global
national up next blackout Tuesday social
media going dark for a cause
people all over the world are showing
solidarity for the protests in the US
and many are supporting blackout Tuesday
social media movement started by the
music industry black squares filled news
feeds it wasn't a perfect campaign and
some activists have questioned whether
it's done more harm than good but as
Heather Eurex West explains the act of
online solidarity hasn't gone unnoticed
these are people in Calgary Rudy
balligan has been having a lot of heavy
conversations about race lately with his
9 year old son
the Calgary father says it's always a
concern when he grows up if he gets in a
situation or he gets pulled over by the
cops he's going to be a black child is
that can affect him for work or
opportunities the death of George Floyd
and others has brought up so much pain
for many in the black community when I
first saw it to be honest with you I
cried I was sitting on my couch my jaw
was wide open and as time went on I
might just tears filled my face so when
the talent manager saw the music
industry was taking a moment to pause
and reflect this week he knew it was the
right thing to do a lot of those music
that we make is about you know social
awareness about struggle about personal
you know perseverance and you know it
doesn't matter really what genre music
has always been that healing force
streaming services like Apple music
replaced browsing and regular
programming with a radio stream Tuesday
celebrating the best in black music well
across social media black squares began
to take over feeds it may be small just
for the signs of solidarity still what
may have been a well-intentioned flood
of support wasn't without controversy as
one sociologist pointed out on Twitter
why would you want the black lives
matter or BLM hashtag to be flooded with
black squares erasing people's activism
author Blair Imani agreed all this is
doing is flooding the BLM hashtags with
pointless black squares and burying
important information you can write your
message in texts don't add a hashtag but
don't stop because controversy aside to
people like Chris Steffler this black
out Tuesday initiative has meant a lot I
know that as a black man
as a black Canadian and this is a black
person when I see so many of my white
friends on Instagram posting black
screens that makes me feel good it does
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm donor Friesen thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
you